I suppose associated with that poverty
headspace is the concept that. Money is bad.
Money is evil that.
The whole idea of counting
and being aware of money.
As i think is is an evil
process. And that then.
Develops a desire to not know in our
whole poverty headspace because.
It's in it's more moral to the poor or to
at least think your poor is more moral.
Thing that strikes me about
that poverty headspace is
that it misses a couple of
really important issues
that are not of the poverty headspace
that have the money being evil and space.
Money of course doesn't exist
anyway in the first place.
It's a total figment of our imagination.
Other than the paper that does exist
and the print that is sitting on it.
The. If we didn't know the language
that it was written in if we were from
somewhere else it could be just as much as
the classic of toilet paper.
It doesn't actually have any value
in itself doesn't really exist.
It's purely the figment of
our imagination in the value
that our imagination puts on it.
If all the money in the world was destroyed
at the moment the world would not the
one bit.
Poorer we would still have all of the cars
all of the houses all of the everything
that we actually use we
would not. Lost one thing.
But the whole place would be in total
confusion total mess total depression
and everyone would be totally lost
and unable because of one particular
magic somehow because of this weirdly
figment of our imagination thing called
money people each morning billions of them
actually get up and go and work long hours
and try really hard in order to get these
pieces of paper because they trust
that somehow having these pieces of paper.
They trust that other people will give
them all the things that they want up to
that level so
that money in fact creates trust
amongst four billion people every
morning of the day because of money for
billion people think they can trust each
other to some degree at least a
little bit anything that creates
that much trust can't be all bad.
But. You know. Barter systems.
Have the inherent problem
of having the thing
that you actually want in the other
person's hand right at that time.
The systems beyond
that of the credit systems where you
are in fact transferring labor.
From one person to another
basically require.
Good solid computerization
and an awareness of what work
is being done in the community.
You can have it working as a occurs in the
cities at the moment amongst tradesmen
who are in fact hour working with
each other on other projects anyway.
And so they're aware of the
quality level of the other people
and they essentially getting
part of their spending.
What they might be doing gardening landscaping
there getting part of their regular
spending part dealt with simply by.
Labor barter from one to another.
But that's really a fairly specialized in
those circles where they know each other
already.
The real challenge to get a community
working well in terms of a low
employment a high unemployment valley getting
the actual unemployment level to drop
for instance.
The challenge with
that is to actually take in the economics
of the whole valley to understand what is
occurring economically throughout the
whole valley and to therefore have.
A sense of understanding.
Of a reality of what this
labor credit is really doing.
In the. Every. In the work.
Economics in the everyone
getting up every day and going
and working economics.
And so you actually build up a
visual picture of the whole valley
and of what's occurring and of people
doing all these different works
but you couldn't do it without a can.
As a pretty complex computer level
and you would therefore expect a fair
degree of telephone connection through
to the to the various parts
of the community and to.
Actually satisfy constant
contact into the computer.
To verify any any important transaction.
That whole option.
Is sort of has the comprehensive
complexity where a lot of people in
the existing community would want to
keep talking and arguing about whether
that was a good idea for 500 years
if they could the level of questions
that would come out about whether
that was definitely what the whole
community should do would run forever.
The only way to actually test
that out would be to do it
to floated as a test piece
but getting enough people to agree
about that float it would mean
that you would actually have
to you would have to see.
A million dollars in materials
and other labor go in to get it to
actually be tested in a worthwhile way.
Because.
In order to keep away
from that house problem
and the low value of house problem.
You would actually have to
have some form of currency.
Not transaction currency. Swap
between that internal credit.
And the dollar.
If you didn't have
that then people would believe
losing their freedom from poverty.
They would be caught they would all
this work as they were doing would be
non-transferable and just like the
house. That's only worth a half a.
Third of what it's really were they
would likewise with all their labor.
Be caught in a situation where they
wouldn't be able to transfer the value
and that's why at the moment you've
only got in those barter credit systems
that are occurring. People
can only afford to do.
Maybe a quarter a fifth of
their total labor in that way
but in nim and with such a huge
employment unemployment problem.
One quarter one fifth might be very good
but that's not going to
solve the question here.
The first the first problem
with getting those legal
and in existence was.
A requirement of the co-operative.
Registrar that touraine the shire
council had to give its approval.
To the development. They had
to give its approval to.
A large number of houses being built on
this one property which technically up to
that time would have only normally
been allowed in three or four houses.
And the registrar of cooperatives was
saying that therefore it might be.
Illegal or it might be a ruse.
If a lot of people hundreds of people
bought shares in a co-operative
that was only going to be allowed
three or four houses so.
We had to go to drain
the shire council. And.
Luckily we had wally ducker in
the health department doing.
Thing inspector who was very supportive
and friendly and helpful and.
I suppose it most likely helped in the
background economics of the whole place
that the property had not yet been purchased
on our purchase would be dependent
upon the approval being given.
Also the particular property is. You
know a separate valley from the nimbin.
Town and actual name and valley.
So it had a privacy for the rest of
nimbin. Really out of sight out of mind.
You know in a large part
and. So in the event.
Yeah i put forward the submission
and spoke a little bit
and luckily this extremely conservative
rural national party country party at
that time.
The shire agreed to australia's largest
commu being established inside to own a
show.
Well it was initially about a
thousand and 40. Ton of all fours.
Was a it was an issue about a thousand
and forty if i remember akers
the original purchase price.
Was raised by the owner in the process
of the seven months between the
original agreement
and the final signing of
transfer of contract documents.
It was. I think it.
I think it changed up to one hundred six
thousand dollars to been either just on a
hundred thousand or just below
it and it got moved up. So as.
If thousand acres one hundred thousand
essentially 100 dollars an acre.
For what was half forest maybe more
than half are arrested high ground.
And. With the running down.
To a creek going down the middle of the
creek was coming from tunnel falls
waterfall which is a really spectacular
beautiful waterfall at the top of the
valley and then ran for some kilometer
and a half through the property. Later on.
The other side of the valley
hasn't variously been bought.
Part of it in a small multiple
occupancy separate from time
and part of it by town about
itself. And has come up.
I think the whole the whole valley.
Would be around about
sixteen hundred acres.
Six that's sixteen hundred acres if these
days it's hard to imagine what a beauty
worth it had certainly be worth a
million dollars without the houses on.
It would be worth over a million
dollars without the houses and.
The question of how much value the
houses add depends on what the
headspace of the people are
that are living in them
and you know that's you could you
could go through any range of values.
You could you could look at you could look
at a range of anything from one million
to 10 million dollars. Depending on.
Yeah how you look at it.
I guess the reason why i did not stay a
ton of it sort of that that's not is
that simple. They had to because
my level of friendships.
A ton of all fours and such that.
I i know never at any particular time
decided to not stay attainable for.
Because i knew i could always go
back at any time that i wanted
but i'd never actually built a house a
tunnel because i was too involved trying to
get there is community projects going.
And so i had never had a house and.
So when i got involved with the bush factory.
Starting the co-operative down here.
And it was obviously going to
need a huge amount of effort.
And just time and all the long bits
and pieces and also at that time.
Because i was on lismore city council.
And having a place down here
at the factory means that.
I didn't have a slight hitch
because i didn't have a car.
And i was hitching into council meetings.
And so not having a starter hitch
was suddenly a very useful sort of
easy step easy change.
Well it was in 1976.
That bob marsh who had been the
policeman during the aquarius festival.
And had now been transferred by the
police department out to more real.
Some such place and had.
Therefore decided that he had to
sell the old but a factory in them.
And i was approached by basil
hayter asking whether i wanted to.
Have it and.
I'd been working on the
registration i was of i had in
fact. Yes received their id
strain of. Bush co-operative.
The aim of bush privateer seem to
concentrate on job work creation
and.
So we'd looked at a possible shop
up in the centre of town and
that didn't work out at
that particular time
and then suddenly this offer
came up and so i said.
Well when i said to him straight away.
Yeah that's great and i took it
along to a cooperative meeting and.
The co-operative sort of said well
that sounds great idea how
we're going to finance it.
And we arranged marriage for the
whole the whole purchased house.
And the development of the factory
has run in i suppose the.
The first thing
that was occurring here was
bush supplies which was a food
a food cooperative business
that began a ton of bull force
and had been part of the.
Essential group
that had become involved to
register to form bush co-operative
and it was the first use in
the old cold cold rooms.
Of the butter factory and for. Going on
from that in pretty quick close session.
Was the bush the eta and the summer land
times. Bush design some land times.
Was started by.
Bob craven
and patricia sayers who patricia
is now one of the key workers
in the lismore echo and.
They started the summer land times
with a couple of other people and.
Worked it right through until finally
some around times close they started most
likely sometime in 77 or 78
and ran through to one hundred
eighty three any three shiny for.
And then the theater and later the theater
and gained a sort of cafe restaurant
with and their recording studio.
And later.
Art art studios
and a candle workshop
photographic workshop
and a range of other semi artistic semi.
Of candles and beautiful but i
suppose it's more of just a normal.
Production business.
So.
Well they they haven't really
stuck together in their come in.
Certainly not as they
had begun. There was.
The those businesses as were
most of them started under the
umbrella of the bush co-operative.
But at a certain point of time.
The bush-gore operative voted
itself out of existence.
I decided to ride up and it voted for
the factory to be turned into a strat
or title. Instead of being owned by
a cooperative as a whole. And then.
The individual groups were then given
first option on the particular spaces
that they were using at that time.
And most of them stayed
and continued.
Yes it was originally
company an out strategy.
Bill on cleese was then chris was a.
Oh it was an interesting. Was
an interesting development it.
That's certainly been very successful
and it started in i suppose it started
essentially because i'd been looking at.
The questions with the
co-operative at the bush factory
and one of our options instead of going to
strata title had been to really develop
a company title
and because of various arguments
we ended up going straight up
but in the process of
that i'd really looked at the question of
company title which is a type of title
that is very common in eastern
suburbs sydney of all the flats
that were built before started try to existed
which was only in the sixties i think
before that all of those flights had been
arranged legally under company title
and i'd suddenly connected the
idea of the company title
through into a multiple
occupancy and suggested.
Talk to about that with
tony pago and he felt that
that did work and that was
it was a good combination.
And so i then set about designing in the
broad sense of the.
Of the bill includes community looking
at that for the right piece of land
and i suppose
that piece of land was chosen
mainly because of a huge amount of
individual privacy.
That it gives to so many
you know over 100 houses
but they've all got such a huge sense of
privacy with beautiful spectacular views
especially of sunsets. And.
It could do that on a property
that was going to be a very very
little economic use for anyone else.
It was land that would
basically be wasted as a farm.
Because it was such a
rough property. That.
Farming would be continually just a
huge hassle. I also felt that it.
The property would continually have
a weed problem in terms of lantana
and lots of noxious weeds. And.
That because of
that one of the best ways was to get it
off the sort of cattle land which didn't
really cope with that. And get
it into a cluster village
that would have 100 families
interested in. Beautifying.
The different parts of the valley and i
think that's worked very well that i.
Yes.
Both.
I see which mean yes.
After some years villain then.
Made arrangements with a small city council
to become a strata title after starting
off as a community title.
Sorry as a company title.
There was another option which
would become available now.
But which at the time when they really
wanted to make the change was not a ballot
or a new type of title
could community title.
Which was basically a version of
that company title. On
a multiple occupancy.
But with a specific example
with a specific fixed
arrangements there a company title
can be any number of arrangements of
that whatever your lawyer chooses.
And likewise before it existed.
Strata title strata title was one particular
company title which was then fixed by
law as always having
this particular pattern.
So therefore a solicitor could not just
change some small parts of it which created
a confusion and likewise community
title is another of those except
that it's designed for
out door areas without.
Interconnecting buildings strata
title is for places. There's.
Walls that are shared walls
and such things so they didn't have community
title at the time and billing cliff.
Chose to become part of the strata title
in the process of doing though most likely
were. Affixing their relationship
to each other. More. Then.
On a general commune.
Multiple occupancy in this area because a
lot of the desire a lot of the desire to
not address questions in
the early days of nimbin.
Was a desire for greater freedom that
when setting up town of all fours
we had the place paid for.
Well there was a sort of one
natural wing which said ok.
Well we've made enough decisions
to get the place paid for.
We don't need to make
any more decisions now.
Now we can just let the place be free
and just let the place do whatever
it wants to namely let me be free
and do whatever i want to. And i
promise not to hurt anyone else and.
The reality is that when you have
that many people living together.
You always had conflicts and
differences of opinion.
No matter how much people
try not to hurt each other.
Because people always look at the
things in their life eccentrically
they can't. It's impossible.
Whenever they open their eyes they look at
everything they go centre glee they only
see the world from where
their eyes are at the time.
And automatically whenever they look at
things occurring between their house
and.
The street the road they look at the
mega century so they have differences of
opinion and arguments and that
sort of question comes back to.
Do you try to suggest a structure
to minimize those differences of
opinion and arguments.
Just as you create a structure for traffic
on roads to try to minimize the number
of car accidents. So.
It's not mass individualism i think if you
look at history the point about history
is that.
Every time you move from something like
nomadic society with carries around this
district and then even if
you take those same people.
And put them in an agrarian
society where the farms are fixed
and where they can't just follow the
kangaroos across the whole valley
and kill them wherever they want because
when they go from one to the other
there on someone else's farm.
Even if you look at it in that terms.
It takes a different set of moral ethics
to live in an agrarian society than
in an emetic society
and it takes another set of moral
ethics to live in a mechanical
or a post mechanical world.
The greater freedom.
If you want to have absolute
freedom of anything of any action
that you want to take it any time you need
to live by yourself in the need to live
as no medically as you possibly can
as far away from other people.
Because if you don't then there'll be
some differences of opinion at times.
And that will restrict
your freedom in some way
and.
So. Do you.
Fail you.
The way that and him and he you know the
image of the community. Everyone sharing.
So much everything.
Is it's really strange to.
Test that out in reality and where
they are what part of that sharing.
Was as limited as into a small household.
How much of that sharing like of
land. Was then limited by ok.
But let's not make any rules so
that the sharing is i will agree to share
as long as i can have as much as i want.
You know i see that.
This sharing
and the question of how much sharing was
occurring in the early days is immediately
intricately linked with the question
of freedom. Are you sharing something.
If you can have as much as you want.
Have it goes back to then the number
of people as the number of people have
increased in the valley the the continual
lesson. It keeps keeps coming.
That. We need to really share.
Now no i mean really share this time we
need to really share where you can't have
just anything that you.